Matilda Wormwood is an extremely
intelligent girl at just 12 she has
already read hundreds of novels and can
make stories up in her mind she also has
the ability to solve complex algebraic
equations without the help of a
calculator one would assume that she
goes to the best school in town but in
fact it is the exact opposite Matilda's
arrogant parents Mr and Mrs wormwood are
still bitter over the fact that they
gave birth to a girl hence they try
their best to suppress Matilda as much
as they can they constantly make fun of
her Hobbies reprimand her for the
smallest of reasons and most importantly
don't let her go to school Matilda has
gained all of her intelligence with the
help of books which she receives from
her neighbor and close friend Mrs Phelps
despite her strange life she has always
had a smile on her face but one day
something good finally happens to her
from a nearby School two teachers visit
the wormwood residence to check if the
children are being educated properly the
cunning parents quickly lie that their
daughter has been homeschooled but the
female teacher Miss honey knows that
something is up later she visits Matilda
alone and inquires if she wants to go to
school the little girl is scared of her
parents but miss honey promises to teach
her literature if she joins this finally
convinces Matilda and she says yes
before heading upstairs later as she is
in her room reading a book as usual her
arrogant dad barges in he chastises her
for talking to the teacher and not
playing along with his story he then
reveals that as a punishment she will be
sent to crunchem Hall the most notorious
School in town the headmistress Agatha
Trunchbull is a big scary woman who is a
former Hammer throwing Champion she has
a very distinctive way of keeping
children in order by punishing them
savagely Matilda is obviously scared
that she is being sent to crunchem Hall
so to get back at her father she comes
up with a plan later when her parents
are busy watching the television she
sneaks into their room and mixes their
Cosmetics together Mr wormwood arrives
shortly after and uses a serum to
massage his head when he checks in the
mirror though he learns that that his
hair has turned completely green this
takes him by surprise so he heads to
confront Matilda only to find her fast
asleep the little girl is just
pretending to be asleep but her dad
doesn't know this so he walks away in
confusion the next morning Matilda gets
up early and heads to her new school
however when she arrives she finds that
the gates have not been opened yet her
best friend Mrs Phelps spots her and
reveals that she is actually a full hour
early now with nothing to do Matilda
decides to narrate a story that she has
recently made Mrs Phelps being a lover
of books as well immediately agrees and
The Story begins once upon a time there
was a famous escapologist that fell in
love with a beautiful acrobat both of
them were Professionals of their
respective traits and a lot of people
admired them soon they got married and
started performing as a Duo however they
were still sad as there was one thing
which they did not have a child years
passed by but a breakthrough never came
hence to divert their minds from it they
came up with a daring plan which would
sure really make headlines throughout
the world one day in front of a large
circus audience the couple announced
that they will perform the world's most
dangerous stunt it is called The Burning
woman hurling through the air with
dynamite in her hair over sharks and
spiky objects caught by the man locked
in the cage sounds crazy but the title
could use some work at this point Mrs
Phelps is captivated by the story but
when she says what happened next Matilda
says I don't know since she has a habit
of making up stories she will need time
to think about the rest just then the
gate finally opens and Matilda along
with another new girl gets inside there
is a large statue of Mrs Trunchbull
throwing a hammer ball at the entrance
as the two girls look around the place
in awe suddenly the other students
welcome them with a musical number oh
God no they mentioned that the school is
like a prison and that there is no
escaping it one can run but they cannot
hide from The Vicious headmistress that
is Mrs Trunchbull she will make sure
that all the students are beaten up and
straightened out before they graduate
after a while Matilda finally reaches
her class and by coincidence it is being
taught by none other than Miss honey
unlike Mrs Trunchbull she is an
empathetic and kind woman who loves to
be with children as the classboard is
filled with algebraic equations which
the seniors wrote at night Miss honey
asks Matilda to polish it off however
instead of cleaning it with a duster the
little girl starts solving the equations
Miss honey is left in complete and utter
disbelief when she sees that Matilda has
solved every equation correctly
realizing that she is not a normal girl
Miss Honey inquires what else she does
in her free time Matilda replies that
she reads novels like the Lord of the
Rings hearing this the entire class is
astounded too after the class is over an
impressed Miss honey decides to approach
the headmistress and tell her about
Matilda's Talent then we finally get a
first look at Mrs Trunchbull she is a
giant woman who wears an army uniform
even at school there are several
trophies in her room that amplify how
good a hammer thrower she was Miss honey
nervously tells her about the new girl
but as expected Mrs Trunchbull is not
interested she doesn't want want to give
any students special attention and
certainly does not want to educate them
all she desires is punishing the
students and making their lives
miserable sounds like a musical number
no oh okay in the next scene when
Matilda reaches home she excitedly
reveals the details of her first day at
school but her parents could care less
Mr wormwood who is a car salesman by
profession has just sold some luxury
cars by illegally modifying their parts
he has made a good amount of cash which
makes Mrs wormwood happy however the
honest Matilda is far from impressed she
berates her dad for cheating on others
and hearing this the latter snatches her
book and tears it apart Matilda is
heartbroken but she has just the perfect
idea for Revenge the next morning she
again sneaks inside her parents room and
pours a good amount of glue inside her
father's hat she then hands it over to
her unsuspecting father who wears it
casually and departs for work later at
school while Matilda is disgusting with
her new mates a frightened boy suddenly
arrives asking for help apparently
someone poured syrup on Mrs chair and
now she is suspecting that the boy did
it hearing this all the students become
scared as the boy will most likely end
up in choki a brutal punishment box
where the naughtiest of students are
kept however Matilda remains calm and
she comes up with a plan she urges the
frightened boy to lay down and asks all
the students to throw their coats over
him just as he becomes completely hidden
Mrs Trunchbull arrives looking for him
Matilda directly points at the pile of
coats and reveals that the boy became
exhausted and collapsed about 30 minutes
ago they covered him with coats hoping
it would protect him from the Sun yeah
that yeah this angers Mrs Trunchbull and
she was really hoping to punish the boy
now since she has to release her anger
somehow she turns towards an innocent
girl with ponytails Mrs Trunchbull
asserts that she doesn't like ponytails
and with this excuse she grabs the Girl
by her hair and swings her around like a
hammer ball as everyone watches in
horror she launches the girl outside the
school premises fortunately she isn't
hurt and she returns back as if nothing
happened after school Matilda meets Mrs
Phelps and continues with her unfinished
story after the escapologist in acrobat
announced their deadly stunt they hired
a manager to help with the promotions
she was the stepsister of the acrobat
but was always cruel and menacing she
also was a former Hammer throwing
Champion meanwhile the escapologist got
on stage and revealed to thousands of
people that the show won't go as planned
because his wife is actually pregnant
the crowd paused for a while but then
they erupted in Applause everyone was
happy that the two were finally going to
be parents however the Arrogant manager
interrupted the couple's emotional
moment and explained that since she had
spent a lot of money on promotions the
show would have to go on if not she will
call the police on them with this the
escapologist in the acrobat reluctantly
prepared themselves for the
death-defying stunt Mrs Phelps is
curious to know what happens next but
just like last time Matilda does not
know she then departs but not before
promising to meet the next day the
following day at school while everyone
is having lunch in the canteen Mrs
Trunchbull suddenly arrives apparently
someone stole her chocolate cake and ate
it she warns the thief to come and
reveal themselves just then a tiny but
obese boy burps out loud and when the
stench reaches Mrs Trunchbull she licks
it and realizes that he is in fact the
culprit enraged she decides to punish
him she orders her chefs to prepare a
large chocolate cake and all the boy has
to do is eat it fully failing to do so
will result in him being sent to the
choki the cake is Giant and all the odds
are stacked up against the boy but with
the encouragement of his friends he
manages to eat it whole Mrs Trunchbull
is taken aback by the turn of events but
she doesn't want to give up hence she
comes up with an excuse and drags the
boy to the choki despite Matilda's best
efforts to save him after school Matilda
approaches Mrs Phelps and starts
narrating the remainder of her story The
escapologist in the acrobat readied
their positions and the stunt began it
was a nervous one but at the end both of
them escaped from their shackles in the
nick of time however fate it had
something else written for them due to a
mishap the acrobats slipped and dropped
to the floor resulting in numerous
fractures she managed to survive but
only long enough to Bear the child the
escapologist was devastated at the loss
of his wife but he promised to give his
daughter the best life that he could
however things only get worse from there
since he was always busy with work the
escapologist invited the evil manager to
look after his daughter when he left for
work the woman always tormented the
little girl and made her work but one
day the escapologist found out about
this and promised to take revenge he
angrily left in his car and that was the
last time he was seen he never came back
home that night while Matilda is at home
she surprisingly moves a trash can
without touching it apparently her
intelligent brain is capable of
Performing Telekinesis the following day
at school while miss honey is teaching a
lesson to all the students Mrs
Trunchbull arrives in a weird uniform
she declares that today phys Ed or
physical education classes are going to
take place Place hearing this all the
students become scared but Mrs
Trunchbull leads them to a field with a
weird musical number which only
glorifies how she became a champion in
the past after a while they arrive at
the field which turns out to be a brutal
Camp there are Barbed wires high fences
and even mines the students will have to
cross the entire thing without any rest
Matilda is left speechless by the
cruelty so she comes up with a plan she
asks her friends to drop her pet newt
inside Mrs trunchbull's water glass the
latter obliges and when the cruel
headmistress sees the Newton there she
becomes enraged she tries punishing
every student on site but a Fed Up
Matilda stands up to her and calls her a
bully she then picks up the same glass
using her telekinesis powers and smacks
Mrs Trunchbull in the head with it at
the same time the cheeky Newt sneaks
around inside her knickers and starts
moving around this is enough to send the
Arrogant headmistress running to her
office and after all the students are
gone Matilda calls Miss honey and
displays her Newfound Powers this
surprises the teacher but she promises
to keep it a secret later the two walk
home together and talk about their
hobbies and interests as their bond
grows stronger Miss honey invites
Matilda to her home it is a small
cottage in the middle of a forest
Matilda inquires about her parents and
Miss honey reveals that she doesn't have
any she was an infant when her mom
passed away and her dad disappeared
years later she was left in the care of
her cruel step Aunt who cunningly took
her home away and left her to rot in
this house when Matilda hears this
flashes of the escapologist in the
acrobat come to her mind then it finally
Dawns on her that the story she was
narrating is in fact a real one miss
honey is actually the daughter of the
escapologist and the acrobat now she is
even more hell-bent on exacting revenge
against the cruel headmistress Matilda
wants to defeat her and retrieve Miss
Honey's home but when she reaches home
her parents deliver some bad news the
faulty cars that Mr wormwood sold were
actually discovered and now the mafia is
after them so the entire family will be
moving to Spain the next day Matilda
cries tears of Sorrow as she hears this
she doesn't want to leave but she has no
other choice the next day however she
decides to attend school one last time
in a dark room Mrs Trunchbull has
summoned all the students for a spelling
competition the rules are simple if
someone makes a spelling error they will
be punished Inside the choki Box she
then brings out one of these boxes and
it is revealed that it has razor-sharp
thorns in it soon the competition begins
initially some students give correct
answers as Miss honey has taught them
well but then Mrs Trunchbull brings up a
long word that doesn't even exist when a
kid fails to answer she starts dragging
her to the chokey but just then the
other students start revolting they
purposely give wrong answers believing
that Mrs Trunchbull cannot punish all of
them at once but to their horror the
cunning head mistress has several
chokies set up in place just when it
appears that all students are going to
get punished Matilda decides to take
matters into her own hands at first
using her powers she writes on the board
and warns Mrs Trunchbull to go away when
the latter doesn't listen Tilda joins
some nearby chains and makes a large
humanoid figure out of them the Towering
figure destroys all the chokies one by
one leaving Mrs Trunchbull stunned then
Matilda uses her next move she binds Mrs
trunchbull's hair into two ponytails and
starts swinging her with the help of
them the next second The Arrogant
headmistress is launched out through the
ceiling that's how you solve your
problems straight up murder when she
reaches the surface she drops her house
keys and quickly makes a run for it Miss
honey picks up the keys and becomes
delighted that she can finally live at
her family home now later all the
students gather around and thank Matilda
for driving out the crazy woman however
their happy moment is short-lived when
Matilda's parents arrive in a car and
tell her to get in they only have one
hour to reach the airport and fly away
the little girl reluctantly agrees and
approaches them but right then miss
honey shows up and asks Mr wormwood if
she can keep Matilda at first he has
taken aback but when he realizes that
he'll have one last person to look after
he agrees Matilda also says yes and she
bids her parents a proper goodbye she
even takes off the glued hat from her
dad's head the movie ends as Matilda and
Miss honey reach their home a home that
the escapologist and the acrobat once
lived in subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching